we wish you a Merry Christmas we wish
you didn't see anything
welcome bros to a Christmas special
episode I've selected the very finest of
the finest
Christmas games out there shut up
the first game is called Santa Claus get
it cause it'll get to you don't worry
about it all right well I guess I'll
have to stop him with snowballs
all right well [ __ ] me oh god that face
Hey hey [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of my way
I just straight-up murder someone
awesome oh there is what the hell are
you do who throws give ah right in the
face you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up
oh god he got his minions you'll never
get me alive
oh god Santa you're creepy as [ __ ] I'm
gonna SuperSpeed ah [ __ ] I died great
gameplay great soundtrack mediocre
fun-ness ten out of ten hi Jen this is
practically the new Call of Duty it's
almost as good come on piece of [ __ ]
right in the [ __ ] face I hate shot
fight to me like a man Santa Claus is
almost dead I'm almost dead - oh God
they already know no no you'll never get
me alive
except those two times said you did you
see oh god what is he doing I'm so
scared
Santa why are you [ __ ] out presents
his ass exploded well he is sent a
scoffs no wait okay I just never been so
scared in my life
say it say it say it again I swear to
God again please say it again okay
no snow no that was Santa Claus would
rate so this is chaos Santa I'm playing
as a bald guy and a bald guy in a Santa
suit Santa what are you doing fight back
Santa
no [ __ ] yeah that's right
fight back Center you can get that bald
son of a [ __ ] not that there's anything
wrong with being bald
here comes fate ow that Santa that's it
that's [ __ ] it oh they're hugging it
out all right really wish I got those
three minutes back Merry Christmas
Island Santa yes my favorite game
here we are quiet Santa's coming if you
didn't have nightmares before then well
you will now oh all right Santa's coming
is that the Christmas tree what a great
Christmas tree what is so [ __ ]
interesting shut your damn mouth oh I
have to sneak in so he doesn't see me
but he's so interested in everything so
oh my god he didn't [ __ ] see me
I'm just [ __ ] out a bunch of
presents here because that's what Santa
Claus does best there we go and he's
still interested fight the Santa power
cause hello Jesus great job this
Christmas they said there's a giant text
saying come here so I guess what's wrong
with my ass can we talk about that
it looks like Santa's done a great job
once again I'm ready to never play that
game again all right I loved it I don't
want to rate this one too much so 11 out
of 10 next game is just called Santa and
I'm farting by picking up cookies North
Pole okay did you know that that's
that's where we are right there's giant
presents everywhere in the North Pole
that's good to know and the forest oh it
looks like there's some cook it's
already God I hear something that's
really weird but hey there's a cookie
eat the cookies all right so now we come
to the really good ones
sonica Christmas City Oh
oh-oh-oh
[Music]
let's try that again
oh my god the map is procedurally
generated rated oh my god I gotta go
fast except not really go slow no what
what happened what happened I went to
space this has to be like I don't want
to I don't want to get out of line here
but this has to be my favorite sonic
Christmas game ever
I haven't played any others in this one
but it's still my favorite oh god no
it's just gotta go fast I guess well
[ __ ] me okay you know [ __ ] this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
all right this game is called basketball
Christmas wait one ah these this games
just makes me upset like the who came up
with that who who thought that was a
[ __ ] it let's just play alright um nope
nope nope Jesus did not die for this
next game please alright so this is a
twerking something I don't know add a
photo of you or friends hey we're all
there oh my god Santa's workshop what
what I'm again AK and Trey oh nice yes
cray oh nice nice
no I'm not gonna join just for that [ __ ]
thank you well I have a weird boner
right now I don't know next game it's
cold Mary [ __ ] miss wait oh oh
so I'm Santa and I will now sit here oh
nice
how much [ __ ] can one man have well
there's a spin fun funfun funfun alright
well I hope this video put you in the
festive mood bros I just want to say I
hope you have an amazing Christmas with
whatever you'll be doing Edgar would
like to say something as well please
save me from a gang we hope you have a
great Christmas and a Happy Holidays and
watch a lot of it YouTube videos mine in
particular in that big way alright
thanks for being awesome there's a
brofist from me and Edgar Oh double kale
oh it's a ripoff of goat simulator let's
play it
I can either be demon from Hell or board
demon from hell I'll go with pork even
thank you
[Music]